hey youtubers is Charlie so for my
Doctor Who bonus video this week I
wanted to talk about all the new
characters that they've cast for series
8 so far they're about 12 of them total
but I've grouped some of them together
just because they appear in some of the
same episodes so there's also been a lot
of rumors about the Rani as well as the
master but I'm just gonna talk about the
people that they've officially announced
first so if you're finding me for the
first time I'm just feeding out a steady
diet of Doctor Who videos until we get
to the premiere of series 8 which is a
long long ways off so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and feel
free to leave me suggestions for future
bonus videos to do in the comments below
so this is how I'm going to organize the
video I'm going to talk about each new
character including Peter Capaldi and
then list what we know about them what's
been confirmed and then some of the
rumors that we've heard about them so
for instance you know we know Peter
Capaldi is gonna play the 12th doctor
but there's also a rumor that he might
secretly be playing the master which is
a little bit ridiculous but that's gonna
you know go in the rumor portion I do
have some episode details but I'm gonna
save that for a separate video but let's
get started at the top number one is
Peter Capaldi as the twelfth doctor or
thirteenth depending on how you count
the war doctor but here's what's been
confirmed the BBC has officially
announced Capaldi as the doctor so
barring any crazy plot twists he'll
complete series eight with a regular
Christmas special there's been no
announcement as to series 9 so we'll
have to wait and see if he stays on
there has been a lot of talk about
Moffat departing whenever Capaldi leaves
but tentatively let's assume they're
both here through series 9 next year so
here's the biggest rumor I've seen for a
couple D that he actually is playing the
master and that's why he's only here for
one series so it hasn't been confirmed
that he's only staying for one series
that's just what he's currently signed
to and I think it's a rubbish rumor
anyway because the BBC officially
announced him as the doctor and they
wouldn't do that if he was gonna
secretly be someone else and add to that
we literally saw Matt Smith regenerate
into him during the last Christmas
special number 2 Jenna Louise Coleman of
course as Clara Oswald she's only been
confirmed through series 8 just like
Capaldi so no word on series 9 yet but
primarily she'll still have a warm
relationship with the new older doctor
most of the onset pics of them show her
in generally good spirits which is a
really good thing
the only rumor that I've heard about her
is that she will leave after series 8
but I think it's more likely that she'll
leave whenever Capaldi leaves and
whatever new doctor comes along will get
a new cook
just like whenever Matt Smith came on
and he got Amy and Rory number 3 Samuel
Anderson is Danny pink so a lot of sites
are quoting him as a full-on companion
Rory style like a companion that doesn't
pour the TARDIS right away but later in
the series becomes much more important
officially the BBC is just calling him a
new recurring character at Clara's coal
Hill School as another teacher so
rumours this is actually where it gets a
little bit more interesting because a
lot of people are thinking that he's
going to be like Derek Jacobi in series
3 you know someone who is secretly the
master just masquerading as someone else
we haven't seen any footage of him yet
so until then it's gonna be really hard
to guess what his character arc is and
if in fact he is pretending to be
someone he's not master or no master as
for his relationship with Clara I'm not
expecting him to be a love interest
since that's kind of been done to death
based on what the producers in the cast
are saying series 8 is gonna be much
darker and more serious than the
relationship comedy that Doctor Who
turned into during Matt Smith's run that
doesn't mean there won't be any romance
it just means the story's not gonna turn
on love triangles number four Tony way
is Alfie in case you don't recognize him
he's totally playing sword on toast on
Game of Thrones right now yay for
crossovers in series eight he's
appearing in episode one so he'll be on
right away once the series starts it's
not a huge part but it ties into the
Jack the Ripper plot there really aren't
any big rumors for his role since it's a
one-off and he's gonna appear right away
number five Tom Reilly is Robin Hood
this is part of one of the episodes that
Mark Davis is writing called robots of
Sherlock that's the name of the episode
so you can understand why Riley is
called Robin Hood there's also a lot of
pictures of Jenna Louise Coleman from
that episode wielding a bow and arrow in
a period costume it looks really cool no
big rumors on this episode other than
the robots in question are gonna be the
clockwork droids because those
characters are rumored to return number
6 Ben Miller as an unnamed villain the
episode he's starring in is also one of
the two that Mark Gatiss is writing and
we know one of those is the Robin Hood
episode but we don't know what the other
one is Stephen Moffat said that he would
be playing a storming good villain
I don't know if that's meant to be taken
literally as in weather storm or
figuratively as in storm of robots a la
robots of Sherwood his casting
announcement was made the same week as
Tom Riley's Robin Hood announcement
so for now let's just assume that his
villain will appear in that sherwood
episode there aren't any real rumors
first character he's also supposed to be
a one-off character you know in just one
episode so anytime anyone not doctor who
has cast and has a beard right now it
seems like everyone thinks they're gonna
be the master number 7 Robert Goodman as
reg his character will appear in episode
4 with a whole bunch of other guest
actors that were just announced at the
same time whenever Samuel Anderson was
cast before series 8 Goodman actually
also started a bunch of other Doctor Who
serials and played a monster named the
mandrill during the fourth doctor's run
no other big rumors about his character
but my number 8 I grouped together two
people that are also in that episode
four with him it's Jonathan Bailey and
Pippa Bennet Warner we don't really have
any info about their characters so I'm
gonna move on to number 9 which is
actually a pretty important person
Keeley Hawes as Miss delphox one of the
really important villains we actually
know quite a bit about her character
she's gonna be an evil banker and her
episode will take place in the distant
future somewhere in the middle of series
8 the big rumor is is that because she's
such an amazing actress her character
could secretly be the Rani or even the
female master there is some precedents
for gender swapping but I think it's
more likely that she's just a one-off
villain that she's gonna be really big
it might return in like a future series
number 10 Michael smiley as Colonel Bleu
he'll be starring in episode 2 the
second of been Wheatley's two episodes
it seems like those episodes will be one
big story broken into two pieces so he's
probably gonna be someone who's helping
the doctor Clara and the Paternoster
gang solve the Jack the Ripper mystery
that's rumored to be the basis of that
story and my last big group of people
number 11 the Paternoster gang and Paul
Hickey is inspector Gregson everyone
knows Madame vastra Jenny and Strax
but Paul hickeys inspector gregson
character was last seen in the snowmen
the 2012 Christmas special
they'll all be part of that first
episode so that's all the new characters
that we know about officially so far but
you know for instance Neil Gaiman said
that he's creating a new monster and
there's a couple episodes that we don't
know anything about yet I do have
information on about 9 of the 13
episodes but I'm gonna save that for
future video so be sure to subscribe to
get it
also be sure to leave me suggestions for
future bonus videos you want to see me
do we still have a long long time before
series 8 premiere I'm expecting it to
come by the end of the summer or August
at the latest though
so also a lot of you have asked me about
video updates too so all you have to do
is follow me on social like Twitter
Facebook Instagram I usually post
updates there so all the links for that
are down at the bottom of the
description so right now you can click
here to get my top 10 picks for brand
new Time Lords in series 8 or series 9
and click here to get my top 10 scary
episodes of classic Doctor Who thank you
so much for watching I'll see you this
weekend orphan black is back so
everybody high fives